[Music]
mr. Ramirez was told he was not under
arrest yet he was refused use of the
bathroom that's violation of civil
rights either wait and address this a
try though I would like to address it
now I'm just saying mr. Israel if guards
in this courtroom would not allow you to
use the bathroom you would by all
definition be detained over the whole
tree of contempt if you continue to
pursue this you're asking me to obey an
erroneous Court decision you tell me to
wait in my experience for you okay find
you in contempt
[Music]
it's an enema of sunshine taking a
nanosecond off of your assembly line
rubber stamp existence Israel they'll
talk about what to expect if you are
arrested we're gonna wrap I don't mean
hip hop I'm sorry why the sisters
standing in a brother city as gendered
and sexist and polite and patronizing
and polite this law firm is run a
deficit for years
you're firing me where did cornerstone
of activism you're inspiring I'm tired
of doing the impossible for the
ungrateful you gotta make a living
take care of yourself
[Music]
no Lucy says hold up step worth a lot
don't tell nobody everything we discuss
will be not potential the man who did it
I know where he is I want to reward cash
the world is full of wonderful things
what are you what do you think when I
move in I just heard something about you
from a solid source you knew where I was
God I got you any time I want
God these are dangerous people
when I'm concerned about you
I begin up on the flesh nemesis added
nothing taken up you don't just walk
away from this
[Music]
I could finish this
each one of us is greater than the worst
thing we've ever done
[Music]
you